and President Trump goes to Capitol Hill
tonight to deliver this year's State of
the Union address his wide-ranging
speech will touch on trade immigration
and economic policy the president is not
expected to mention the Russia
investigation major Garrett is at the
White House major good morning good
morning president Trump's message to his
supporters will be as follows you will
write to bet on me because the economy
is improving and border security is at
the center of the immigration debate
it's a midterm election message designed
to mobilize the Trump faithful and help
Republicans retain control of Congress
president Trump said he will use his
first State of the Union address to do
what most presidents have done sell his
accomplishments the Trump White House
also embraced another ritual promising
to speak to Main Street and strike a
bipartisan tone what is the nexus
between what has happened and your own
life and then how is that a framework
for working together in 2018 the
president will propose a tougher
approach to trade 1.7 trillion dollars
for infrastructure and an immigration
compromise including 25 billion dollars
for a border wall and cuts to legal
immigration coupled with a path to
citizenship for 1.8 million undocumented
immigrants known as dreamers nearly a
dozen House Democrats will boycott the
speech undercutting the president's
bipartisan message this is an amazing
moment speech writer and senior policy
adviser Stephen Miller helped author the
speech and it will reflect his belief
that mr. Trump is the leader of a global
populist movement president Trump's the
most gifted politician of our time and
he's the best orator to hold that office
in generations the Democrats have
selected Massachusetts congressman
Joseph Kennedy to third to deliver the
official party response but in a sign of
party diversity Republicans suggest it
might be divisions there will be four
additional unofficial responses
representing various Democratic
constituencies Norah all right major
thank you so much